what time was it you cannot tell me what
time was it when minik began her journey
home altogether I'm 30 and you've rican
you've read it here right so this is
important right when the graph is going
downward that means she's on her return
journey so an up and down here means a
change in direction okay
so you've all told me it was what was
that part d1 30 P and that's when she
starts heading home now to work out how
much she traveled all together she went
away from home up to this spot here
wherever that was quite a ride actually
and then she came home so there's an
outward journey and then there's a
homeward journey I guess so we need to
add those together what is the total
length of one side of that journey 65 so
I could say the total distance equals
the number you just told me 65 65 165
what woman is very good and as you
suggested I'll double it because she has
to come home as well so what is that by
the way excellent all right well where
is the detour I added more details to
this story to make it more interesting
that's fine now we're almost finished
here we want to work out just down the
bottom here the average speed during the
homeward journey and this is what I put
here right we did average speed in Part
C for the first part the first leg right
so we need to know and I've written it
there in Part C over there right for
Part F I need to know the distance to
travel and then how long she took to
travel that distance so this is her
speed what is the distance she traveled
on her homeward journey we just
established was 65 right how long does
it take to get there hmm I'm hearing a
few answers here which is interesting
okay how can we count so you all told me
like 90 seconds ago that 130 was the
time right there when she started on her
way home yeah and then what time does
she arrive home so how long is there
between half-past one and four
two hours 30 minutes so I'm gonna write
2.5 hours there Louise did you have a
thought or question oh yeah
310 minutes
310 hold on a second how many minutes is
two and a half hours 60 120 150 now this
is interesting I'm just going to pause
on this before we leave off it
converting to minutes is nice for one
reason but it's kind of gross for
another reason what's nice about minutes
that's an actual question what's nice
for about minutes than hours yeah I
didn't have any decimals no parts right
here I've got like a fraction decimal
however I'm not gonna use minutes I'm
gonna stick with hours can anyone just
me why say handy what do you think yeah
I don't want to do the unit change I
want to stay in km/h what did you get by
the way 26 kilometers per hour we have
one final question which I'm struggling
to read it was how long did Monique I
think it was how long did she stay stay
stay stop right is her brakes yeah how
long did she break for like I have a
look whoops it is it so this question is
how long did she stop for which parts of
the graph we're looking for yeah the
stationary the horizontal sections and
you can see them here and yeah up the
top here so what's the total that's an
hour and a half ninety minutes either
those is fine